هذه الكميات الكبيره من البصل المشوي
جاهزه للاكل في تقليد سنوي غريب باسبانيا
يتوافد الى العشرات المشاركين والاف
الزوار
[موسيقى]
في مدينه فانس الواقعه في منطقه كتالونيا
الاسبانيه يقام مهرجان اكلين فريد من نوعه
الطعام هنا ليس من اطباق المطبخ الاسباني
وانما كميه وفيره من البصل الابيض المشوي
على النار
مئات الكيلوغرامات من البصل الطازج زرعت
في حقول حول المدينه
وجنيت بايادي السكان المحليين الذين اتوا
بالهاء الى وسط ساحه بفاس لبدايه طقوس
المهرجان مع بدايه فصل الربيع من كل عام
وتزامنا مع نضج محصول البصل هناك الذي
يسمى بصل الربيع في اسبانيا
[موسيقى]
هذا المهرجان يعود تاريخه الى القرن
التاسع عشر
ومن بين الطقوس المتعارف عليها في المنطقه
خلال الاحتفالات مسابقه اكل البصل
شارك بالمسابقه حوالي 37 متنافسا وقفوا
امام مائده كبيره وامامهم كغمات من البصل
والفائز منهم من ياكل اكبر عدد من حبات
البصل هذه
[موسيقى]
كان الفائزه في نسخه عام 2023 حيث اكل 222
حبه بصل بوقت قياسي بلغ ساعه واحده وجاء
بعده رامون بتناوله 25 بصله بينما احتل
المركز الثالث جوردي وتناول 175 بصله
[موسيقى]
في مركز
البصل الذي يتم تناوله في المسابقه هو بصل
طول ياكله المشاركون بعد تغطسه بصلصه خاصه
[موسيقى]
المهرجان كان متوقفا بسبب رائحه كورونا
وعاد في 2023 في نسخه حضرها اكثر من 20000
[موسيقى]